we think that we are entitled to comfort
that we have the right to avoid
suffering and hardship and those are
assumptions that our ancestors would
have never made our ancestors
encountered death and pain and suffering
and they said well this is what life is
it's not that they weren't sad about it
okay they were sad they were distraught
the family member dies something
terrible happens but they said this is
what life is life is suffering we
encounter that sort of thing much less
of it and we say no it's not supposed to
be this way it's not fair it's not fair
this is not how life is supposed to be
you see all these videos of gen Z people
that are like in tears cuz they have to
work 9 to5 now in tears about it it's
not supposed to be this way this is not
how life is supposed to be no one in
history thought that way everyone in
history is like well of course you have
to work what else what else are you g to
do in life it's life what do you mean
it's it's not not fair not fair compared
to what